(upbeat music)
- People may not think pizza
tossing is a serious sport.
It really is; it's a lot of hard work.
My name is Tony Gemignani,
and I'm a 12-time
World Pizza Champion.
I have two Guinness Book of World Records:
one for most consecutive
rolls across the shoulders
in 30 seconds.
It was 36 rolls across the shoulders,
36 or 37, yeah.
We'll say 37.
So pizza acrobatics are
tricks with pizza dough.
A lot of people ask me, you know, pizza throwing,
how do you describe it?
It's kind of like what a
Harlem Globetrotter does
with a basketball, but we do with a pizza.
You know, around the back, across the shoulders,
through the legs, two at a time,
on the ground, spinning in your hands.
The difference between,
you know, a basketball and a pizza
is it misshapes, it gets
bigger, it gets softer.
It's not like it's juggling balls
that are always the same.
It's pretty magical.
(audience cheers)
So every year in Las
Vegas, there's Pizza Expo
and at the Pizza Expo
there's a World Pizza Games.
When you walk to that stage,
there's acrobats from all
around the world competing.
They'll be getting judged by a panel
of three to five judges.
- [Announcer] 8.5, 9.5, nine, nine.
- And those judges will
look for dexterity,
creativity, difficulty.
And as they're judging them,
they'll look for drops and
they'll look for transitions
from trick to trick.
There's about a two to three
minute routine of music,
they have to nail it.
They've been practicing all year for it.
There's a trick in the
sport called the Gemignani,
my last name, it's a trick that I did.
It's two across the
shoulders and you catch it.
Nobody loves pizza more than me.
Even I have it on my
chest, it's pizza for life.
(audience cheers)